Justine did you just drop your camera in
there you have to go get them get in
there I called it you did you actually
did call it I would have dove in there
Justine Oh oh my heart hurts that camera
is so expensive you did say it was so
dark oh my god I didn't want to tell you
this snake I was trying to see if that
was a snake is it okay why you're in
there go see if it's a snake
Justine oh my god I knew you were
because these rocks are very unstable is
that a snake Yuma's gotten eaten well
how do you feel that water's cold
Wow I'm sorry judge I think getting my
footage from today really nope holy Sh
I just lost my camera in the water I'm
oh nice breathe thank you on my own so
Ron yourself I also I also didn't see me
my footage for today oh oh I'm in shock
I'm slightly in shock all your footage
isn't it
yeah I'm in shock Joey I might know just
from today I'm a drop room porch a
Sipapu
[Music]
where's where's my baby
something bad happened guys you probably
just saw it in that previous clip it's
gone it's that's I mean it's there's no
hope not
pretty sure I just dropped my a 7s mark
- into the pool I was taking a long
exposure shot and it was dark and I
stood up and just it tumbled in and I
started screaming and I didn't know what
to do my mom's like you gotta coping
after it so I'm freaking jump in the
pool it's the deep end I mind you I'm
not a good swimmer at all so then I'm
Joe I'm I'm laughing but I'm crying like
cuz I don't know I don't know how to
process my emotions right now and I'm
I'm flailing and my mom out of the pool
the pool kid like oh oh my god guy that
when I say I can't swim like it's not a
joke like I I was I inhaled water mom
what was I doing let's get a reenactment
is like a terrifying face like I thought
she's no in this sort of a back otter
your arm I'm so stupid I'm so stupid
here's a few photos though that I got
which is crazy because I didn't save any
of the footage that I film today off my
camera but right before I went by the
pool I was like I want to see how my
photos are doing and I sent them to my
phone through Wi-Fi so here's some
photos that
before it's altima device
I'm soaking wet
I'm talking about this whole floor like
I can't Oh God
go take a shower I'm depressed um I
didn't realize you were filming job you
told me to always get the shot never
stop filming you know I sacrificed my
time lapse for you
my mom's blow-drying my camera right now
I'm still in chocolate I'm shaking and
on Twitter
everyone's main concern is the fact that
I can't swim not like I'm so sorry for
your loss
why can't you swim you idiot I can
clearly swim enough to save a camera but
not my life well tomorrow's video will
be a video of a video that I already
edited this footage from my camera that
is no longer with us I'm crafting a
tweet I don't know if it's funny or
means asterik moments after iJustine
sony a7s falls into the pool hey Jess
what are my moon pictures do you like
best this means she's like hey look at
my pictures which one do you like I was
like you're a pig you can have them you
could take it through use it why don't I
use it
right I met a dream I met on three
and let's see that